dans l'actualité de ce vendredi le monde
du football retiendra cette date c'est
michel platini qui a été élu président
de l'uefa l'ancien capitaine de l'équipe
de france n'avait pas ménagé sa peine
c'est avec beaucoup d'émotion qu'il a
appris la nouvelle avec lui sur une
nouvelle page manuel tissier patrice hr
sur plainte inhument jeunes la joie est
contenue
michel platini vient pourtant de
remporter l'une de ses plus belles
victoires
la plus inattendue à 52 ans il pousse le
suédois johan sonne à la retraite et
devient le nouveau patron du football
européen
je suis ému énormément ému mais je suis
heureux
à peine élu platine et retrouve ses
parents dans la salle tout le clan
français a explosé de joie à l'annoncé
des résultats
sa famille ses amis tous rêvaient du
triomphe de l'enfant de la balle
pierre conte est d'avoir mis un garçon
comme lui en route quoi parce que depuis
la sagesse illzach hu a même fait voir
de toutes les couleurs de l'image de
foot ça ça a marché chez moi
michel a quand même une dimension et une
image d'homme honnête intègre avec des
idées saines sur le sport le football ça
l'a emporté chez boussac ça me rassure
avec 27 voix contre 23 à lennart
johansson
michel platini s'impose de justesse mais
il entend bien rassembler et ralliera
ses idées toutes les fédérations
européennes
je suis plus un une personne qui
considère que le football est le jeu est
très important et qu'il est temps de
redonner ses vraies valeurs au football
le plus important la troisième vie de
michel platini a commencé aujourd'hui à
düsseldorf
l'ancien numéro 10 de l'équipe de france
sera pendant quatre ans le numéro un en
europe